etonnant non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
il était temps que janvier fit place à
février janvier est de très loin le mois
le plus saumâtre le plus grand bleu le
moins pétillant de l'année les plus sous
doués d'entre vous chers auditeurs
auront remarqué que janvier débute le
premier je veux dire que c'est pas moi
qui ai commencé
et qu'est ce que le 1er janvier sinon le
jour au nid entre tous ou des brassées
d'imbéciles joviaux se jette sur leur
téléphone pour vous rappeler
l'inexorable progression de votre compte
à rebours avant le départ vers le père
lachaise
dieu merci il n'y a pas de quoi mais si
mais si cet hiver afin de m'épargner au
maximum les assauts grotesque de ses
enthousiasmes et hypocrite
j'ai modifié légèrement le message de
mon répondeur téléphonique au lieu de
deux bonjour à tous j'ai mis bonne année
mon cul c'est net c'est sobre et ça vole
suffisamment bas pour que les grossiers
trouve ça vulgaire
plus encore que les quarante cinq
précédents mois de janvier que j'ai eu
le malheur de traversée par la faute de
ma mère celui ci est à marquer d'une
pierre noire
je n'en retiendrai pour ma part que les
glauque et morne soubresauts de
l'actualité dont il fut parsemé rappelez
vous c'est un avocat trop murs qui
tombent
sa veuve qui descendent son petit cheval
pour monter sur ses grands chevaux
la concierge est dans l'escalier madame
villemin est dans l'impasse
tandis que de biture en biture les
graphologues de la sphère qui ne des
soul plus continue à jouer à pincemi et
grégory sont dans un bateau
côté bouillon de culture francis huster
attrape le cid avec jean marais au
progrès de lyon le spécialiste des
chiens écrasés et le responsable des
chats noyer apprenant carsan rachète le
journal se domine pour ne pas faire
grève le 15
premier coup dur balavoine est mort le
16 deuxième coup dur sabatier est
toujours vivant l'espagne faudrait-il
qu'elle fût myope reconnaît israël
le 19
on croit apercevoir mère teresa chez
régine c'était bardos vous inventez
votre le 23 il fait 9 degrés à massy
palaiseau
on n'avait pas vu ça à 23 janvier depuis
1936 et je pose la question qu'est ce
que ça peut [ __ ] le 26 sur tf1 le roi
des [ __ ] dégouline de charité
chrétienne dans une entreprise de
restauration cardiaque pour nouveaux
pauvres
heureusement j'ai mon alka seltzer le 27
l'un des trois légionnaires assassins du
paris vintimille et c'est timidement de
se suicider dans sa cellule
ses jours ne sont pas en danger je n'en
dirais pas autant de ses nuits le 29 feu
d'artifice tragique à cap kennedy bilan
380 tonnes d'hydrogène et d'oxygène
liquide béton langage et le soir du 31
comme tous les autres soirs joëlle
kauffmann embrasse ses deux garçons et
elle rentre dans sa chambre elle est
tout seul ne dort pas très bien enfin
voici février sec comme un coup de
trique et glacée comme un marron avec
son ordi grand quine ou cours sur la
crêpe
c'est le mois de la saint blaise qui rit
dans son ascèse et de sainte véronique
qui pleurent dans les tuniques
c'est aussi le temps du carême où les
maigres chrétiens d'ethiopie peuvent
enfin je n'ai la tête haute dans la
seule gloire de dieu
les statistiques sont irréfutables
c'est en février que les hommes
s'entretuent le moins dans le monde - ne
tuerie guerrière moindre x crapuleuses
moins d'agressions nocturnes dans les
rues sombres du xviiie arrondissement de
paris où la sécurité est elle
habituellement que les arabes n'ose même
plus sortir tout seul le soir jusqu'au
nombre des cambriolages qui diminue de 6
% en février
et tout ça pour quoi et bien après les
enquêtes scientifiques les plus poussées
les sociologues sont parvenus à cette
incroyable conclusion si les hommes font
moins de conneries en février c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont que 28 jours
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
est bon
[Musique]